okay next game
was the international master um
from belgium i think yeah i think i
actually know him we never played but um
he's played against my team this is
mark du trey
he's a veteran international master with
about
2 400 rating
sorry for the munching i've got a little
snack here
i waited a bit before this game started
so
i actually feared another disconnect
because of the long thing
okay
yeah we got um a line of the
modern defense or maybe perk
you could also call it i played the
the solid setup with c3
yeah now i have to watch out for e takes
d4
like edi 4 cd4 and
knight to b4 then
it's it's a question where my bishop
should go i cannot go to f1 because e4
is hanging
and i don't want to give him the bishop
so
um of course the simple
solution would always to capture on e5
but this is
um not very ambitious i try i try this
one
to to get the bishop to b1
if he takes and plays the knight to b4
and you know maybe d5
is an idea here hmm
well let's check if if i take on
i take here you would
want to equip see if he takes the queen
i have
bishop c4 maybe if he takes with the
bishop
alex just exchanged then
to get my knight to c4 with
gain of time
check
we hadn't really taken this a new
account he can take on c3 now
now i'm lucky this is not working knight
c3 bc
queen d3 quinnie a check bishop f8 and
bishop h6 would would have been
the solution to this okay
yeah this is some not the most exciting
position ever
hmm i've got a little bit of a problem
with this bishop on c1
does it have really good development
squares available f4 is taken by the
knight and g5 as well
yeah this is a very solid position for
black
you should be um
at least equal maybe it's a bit
better already because of the
development
yeah maybe he just goes knight f4
to to get the bishop pair
again i want to prevent
neither form
yeah just just a normal but
certainly fine move
want to get out of the d file
of course not not really active but
so don't see it see much
active moves here
maybe this one to get the queens off and
allow bishop g5
if he takes here he takes
yeah the double pawns are not
not a problem in terms of
weakness of pawns but
one problem is the square e4 which i'm
which i gave away
maybe something like knight f6 c4 could
be
annoying
i'm not sure what he's thinking about
him
at least so so deeply
yeah i'm not sure what can you do
yeah knight f6 maybe immediately but
then bishop f4
okay yeah i'm glad to
to get a tempo here and another here
to get my things developed wow
don't have just 95 to get the bishop
here
well this was quick into in four moves
this has gone from
from a slightly worse position to
i think a slightly better position
at least um you would think so at first
glance
with white getting the bishop pair
okay but he's got the idea knight e4 and
also this one is hanging
yeah it's not
so great after all
where i just just go back
if he takes on a2 i maybe have rook a1a7
time warning yeah i need to cover cover
this
okay no g4 get rid of the double pawn
okay i take it
i need to speed up a bit here
just i'm just curious how he
doesn't cover c7
yeah this is an extra pawn and b6 is
just hanging
yeah but i can take here
yeah okay this is uh opposite colored
bishops but
two extra pawns
and he still got some some weaknesses
it's hard to believe that this should be
a draw
i just had four h7
yeah of course he's got the trick here
therefore check but
ok but this pawn is just going through
black resigned
yeah this was a
win out of less than nothing i guess
yeah but he played some some really
weird moves here
f5 already is is just bad i think
it doesn't do much much good and i just
i just get
time here
i know bishop bishop f7
maybe check
here you could maybe simply take on a2
to reduce some material
yeah this is just this better for white
weaknesses on c7 and f5
but um it's a long and not very
pleasant defense he just he just gave me
gave me more material
yeah but this opening wasn't a success i
think
this is just just okay for black i need
to play
play it differently